el informe sustentado por el legislador
Diego Bazán ante la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales al congreso
de Perú pide que el presidente Pedro
Castillo sea inhabilitado durante 5 años
y se ha acusado por supuesta tradición a
la patria por haber declarado en una
entrevista en enero pasado que Perú
podría brindar una salida al mar a
Bolivia el legislador invocó el artículo
118 de la Constitución peruana que
faculta el presidente dirigir la
política exterior y celebrar tratados
internacionales pero no se pueden
alterar los límites del territorio
peruano y según Bazán el mandatario sí
habría atentado contra la Constitución
peruana pero la sesión de hoy donde se
iba a aprobar el informe final fue
suspendida porque hubo un cambio de 4
congresistas al grupo de trabajo el
debate y votación fue reprogramado para
mañana si el informe es aprobado la
comisión permanente del parlamento
peruano nombrará una subcomisión
acusadora para someter a Pedro Castillo
a un proceso donde se requieren 51 votos
para provocar su destitución a Pedro
Castillo solo le la defensa de sus
abogados para elaborar una estrategia
precisamente están pidiendo que Lady
gambones la presidenta de la subcomisión
de acusaciones constitucionales se
inhiba de evaluar la denuncia por
traición a la patria contra Pedro
Castillo porque afirman ella ya tiene un
veredicto preestablecido contra el manda